- [Narrator] Nestled in the
side of the Yoro Mountains,
the Site of Reversible Destiny in Japan
is an experience park
where guests encounter the unexpected.
The park was designed by
artists Shusaku Arakawa
and Madeline Gins, and
consists of sculptures,
pavilions and constantly
changing terrains.
There is an intricate network of 148 paths
and 24 types of plants that emphasize
the changing of the season,
such as cherry blossoms
in the springtime and vibrant
autumn leaves in the fall.
Some of the attractions include
The Critical Resemblance House,
which has a map of Gifu Prefecture,
a region of central Japan, as a rooftop,
and the Reversible Destiny office
that contains an uneven
pastel-colored maze
and a ceiling that mirrors
the design of the floor.
Visitors are encouraged
to explore the site
with the mindset of a
child, to climb, be curious,
and discover different visual perceptions.
But because of slanting
angles, steep hills,
and narrow pathways, the
Site of Reversible Destiny
offers optional helmets to
ensure a safe excursion.